today I want to talk to you about how
the high achievers of life find ways to
overcome their weaknesses
recently Michael Jordan was interviewed
in a new videogame 2k14 regarding who he
would pick as a starting five and this
is what he said pickup game who would I
pick up well five guys would I pick up
to make sure how long to the basketball
Scottie Pippen for sure
Magic Johnson James Worthy and it came a
lot to him I got no chance losing none
at all so that's a pretty interesting
team to pay do you think about all these
NBA players that we haven't picked Salah
John as the greatest Center for him he
picks Pippen which is obvious he picks a
worthy obviously I understand why first
pick in the NBA Draft 1982 he played
with Michael Jordan won the NBA
championship three times national
championship with North Carolina and B
Finals MVP then you have Magic Johnson
five-time championship he's on all these
other great things for the Lakers his
statues outside of the Lakers
so it's interesting team he put together
obviously with all the LeBron James fans
out there kind of makes you think he
still doesn't put LeBron in that
category but even would that being said
what does all of this have to do with
anything well the way the overachievers
find ways to cover up their weaknesses
is by putting an incredible team around
them to cover up their weaknesses you
see Jordan doesn't need to play center
it's not his position he doesn't need to
play one he doesn't need to play power
forward his position is to to card
that's the position he played right a
lot of times we may look at somebody
else and may say that person's better
than me in specific area it's irrelevant
when you're building a team it's not
just about you trying to get good on
everything that everybody's good at you
gotta work with your strengths recently
I read a book called parenting beyond
your capacity by this pastor that wrote
it was given to me as a gift recently by
a friend of mine Cindy and when I read
this book it was a very interesting book
because it says it says parenting is
about building a team around your kids
what I mean by building a team around
your kids he talks about you need to
know the coaches you need to know the
teachers you need to know maybe the
nanny you need to know the friends you
need to know the French parents because
eventually becomes a community around
your kids that are
open your kids and I think the same goes
with finding a team of people that
handle your finances I'm talking a good
CPA I'm talking a good real-estate
person I'm talking a good financial
person I'm talking about a good doctor
for you
a good doctor for your kids a good
person that manages maybe your credit
for you a person that's good at in the
banking area somebody they can develop
in all aspects of your life you could
have a good personal trainer this is all
about fundamentally building a strong
team of advisors could also be your
pastor it could be a friend or on your
wife it could be friend around your
husband but at the end of the day
regardless of who we are and whatever we
do we don't necessarily need to play
basketball to put a team around us no
matter what we do in life whether it's
business family church finance health
regardless what it is it'll come down to
how good you can be on picking a solid
strong team around you and by the way if
you disagree with the team Jordan put
together I'd be curious to hear about
your starting five who you would pick
for your team without being said that's
my message of the week to you and please
be sure to subscribe and share the video
you